あれ今日はプレーぶりを b 4スペイン japanese いい
apologize r
re re re re re you doing
んそれじゃ
みなさんこんにちは
以上にも長いだ長い間日本語のビデオはやってないんですから
今日は日本語で話ししたいと思うんですよ
日本語でこの
私の茶脳はどういうふうに来これからこう変わってきましたかというかそれについて
ちょっと説明したいと思います
毎週まカナダの木曜日
の時に一応英語のままよりも短い利用
3分4分くらいのビデオをやるつもりでそのビデオに対しては必ずその文字
す必ずこれくら短縮っていうかこう書きます
そうすることによって者の英語を
勉強してる人たちはこのターンスクリプトを見て
場合によってこれを
リンクに導入してその中の知らない単語やフレーズを勉強することができます
そしてよりまあ
この理解の可能性がまぁだいたいあの
もっとこうよくなるわけですよねうんと同時にやはり
毎週1回ありは
2週間に一度ぐらいはへ
その英語でない言葉を使ってビデオをしたいと思います
さのビデオについては今のところは外いわゆるも次回助っ人をやるつもりがないんです
これ以上にも二時間かかります
もんですから
え
この前ですねこの前というか昨日はこの7週間という日本でも非常に人気のあった
高
本
のそれがどういうふうにこの言葉の勉強と関係があるかということについて摂津からお
話ししましたこれからはですね英語ででエコノ7つの習慣の
一つ一つですねえ
今もっと子細かくですね深くお話をしてこれどういうふうにこういう習慣が猫の言葉の
勉強は英語の勉強においてですね非常にへ
えまあ
価値があるかという意味
であるまあもんかと
それからですねもう一つ
こうあんまり最近ね日本語は話す機会がないんですよね
それでまぁ最近はもうロシア語も
くらいに顎もですね観光語も勉強してですね
今
日本語を話そうと思えばですね
もし子
自動的にですねほんの的にこう日本語でてくるならばいいです
だしてへ
しかしもしこうこの言葉を探そうと思えば私の今
ほぼ70年もかかっているこの頭の中でですね
ロシア帽かで出てきたり
韓国語が出てきたりするわけですよだから言葉というのはわざと考えて
jr
力を使ってですねその
言葉を探すというのはね非常に効果的じゃないです
なんとなく5こういう雰囲気にですね
うーん入って
5本の的に話しできる
それのほうがですね性格
そしてあのまあそういうのもですね
view 長という一つのまあ側面でもあるわけですよ
だから例えば今日は日本語で話をするという事を決めましてね
しかし日本語はもんなぁ間しばらくも全然使ってない本ですからどういう風に行くを
準備するからと
いうことを考えたらねいろいろ可能性だったんですよ例えば日本語の文法の本を読むか
簡単に読むか
あるいはですね色んなその
何ですか単語ですねもう勉強するか
だけでもそれが役に立たないあるいは人と話しする
じゃあ誰かスカイプを通じて日本語で話しているかだ総理じゃなくてですね
私がちょっと車にね30分くらい入ったものですから
っっこういうあの
オーディオブックを探してましてね私はたくさん
をで僕待っていますもうスペイン語からです中国アロ15からファンそこからすべて
たくさん持ってもすぐいることが同一ことがそれようですね聞きまして
そういう日本語の世界に行き入りました
そういう
一つの別のそのそういう言葉の世界に入りますとですね
感情的にいろんな関係ができるわけよ
感情的にあるいは頭の中でですね
そうしますと
潜在的には下記の頭の中にある
日本語が少し悲劇されるわけですよすぐが出てくる
ボヴェ処理は非常に大事なポイントだと思います
日本日本行く時にですねまぁ最近何年か v てないんですけれども日本にもう5年前
に行った時に
まずはだけ本屋できますよねそれでもたくさんも英語を勉強英語会話
宮なんとか方方向勉強方法
近道やそれが全然船
僕がいないんですよ
いないですあるいはん
と分にそのねえ
高い点数を取るためにはこういう勉強法
こういう単語を勉強しなさいとか僕はそれが信じないっ
やはり
4は子あの
たくさんですね沢山の方
その言葉の生きた経験
行こう
蹴球しないとですね導入しないと
こういう自然的なそういうなんていうんですか
まっスターというかでそれでてこないんですよ部分的に文法を勉強したり
部分で機にこういう単語を勉強したりするのはですね
これは非常にまあ
英語の日本語で言う artificial ですね
自然的じゃないことになりますから非常に弱いです
もっと自然的にですねもう
英語で言うホリスティックで全般的にこの方ば言葉をしその吸収すればそれはあの
長押しする
すぐは壊れないですね
ですごく一緒のことによってはやるたくさん
まずこの言葉は好きでないといけないだけども
全部好きじゃありませんよね例えばいい読むことにしても寄付事にしてもですね全ての
内容が面白くないから好きなものを
港への式なものを聞きたいこと何回も聞いて
そしてある程度集中してこの作家
あるいは5
経済学なる経済学歴史なレキシー
なんでもいいですけどある程度集中してですね
自分が興味の感じるもの
たくさん読んだりたくさん聴いたり聞いたりですね
まあ私がススメするならば臨機にですね
うちのと柄のものあるいはこう
インターネットからいろんなものを導入してそこで勉強するとそうしますと
ス自分のそのそういう生きた
外国語が自分の頭に入ってくる
そういうことになったらですね話しすること自体が
右側出てくるんですよすぐ出てだそういう家をい洗剤
その能力ぜんざい知識があるとすればですねこういう基盤の上で会話というか話の
その能力はですねすぐ開発されます話ししながら
ただそういうあの
ん
何ですか自分の佐野レボラブズ全般的にそういうればらくしないとですね
ただ単に英語会話のどっか行ってですね
週23回をちょっと喋った日ですね自分労組の
a
理解力もそんなにへ
改善しないし号医療もそんなフェイしないし
増えて来ない子ですねそういうのはですねあんまり得意
得策じゃないと思いますまあたくさん僕はノートしましたけどまぁそんなもんですよ
旦那
誰も長いビデオ3巻きたくなるけどで一応これから
英語のビデオですね全部文字がついてついていますからぜひそれを見て
でこれからもですねその
6スペイン語もうこれから紹介しますよねその言葉を押すねスペインなるスペイン語
英語な英語
10部はそれについてのですね一つの全般的な消化という風な
そのビデオも準備しておりますから今年はいろいろとね
レビューだけ面白いよにですねこの言葉の勉強について
皆さんとへ
コミュニケーションですね
これも日本語ですよねやりたいと思いますじゃあ今日はどうもありがとうございました